all right Jenny's with us in Buffalo hi
Jenny how are you there i so appreciate
the opportunity to talk with you mr.
Ramsey I'm honored to speak with you how
can I help my husband and I just
completed baby step 2
and in a few months we're hoping to be
ready to work on college savings and
about 15 years ago we did open a 529
five has a little bit in it but we
stopped contributing so there's only
about 10 grand in it we don't feel that
529 is the best fit for our family and
so I'm just wondering your opinion on
women I stopped I disagree with your
feelings what are you talking about as
far as the fit for my family yeah we
mean I don't want your kids to be
educated oh no I'm in education I'm just
not sure
as far as potential scholarships or for
once before for one possibility or if
they decide trade school or wanting to
work right after school we want to
support them financially at whatever
best Avenue is best for them at that
time okay so what I would do is build a
sufficient 529 for them to get a
four-year college degree and if they get
scholarships you can withdraw the
equivalent amount of scholarship
completely tax-free from that 529 okay
so you're not trapped but you're not
trapped if you got a half-liter a
scholar or something on your staff there
that's going to be great and get freeze
College then you're going to get the
money right back out of the 529 you're
not trapped at all trade school can be
used for 529 okay and what if they
decided to go working trying to get on
on-the-job training yeah
how about that's a dumb idea let me tell
you why okay okay 75% to 80% of the
millionaires that we interview have
higher education this idea that higher
education has completely gone crazy and
no one and everyone needs to abandon the
idea of going to college because of the
Student Loan debacle and because
education is so expensive because people
studies stupid but stuff that's not
applicable
marketplace does not invalidate the fact
the power of education people need to be
smart right absolutely and they make
more money if they're smart fully agrees
we have we do have one kiddo that school
is not really his thing he's a hands-on
kid he's super smart but not not a fan
of school and so we just want to be most
prepared for and I would do a 520 then
and if you take him to a trade school
around or maybe he's a tech tech kid or
something like that he can make a lot of
money have a great career doing that as
you said you know certifications and
that sort of stuff you can use 5.94 most
of that but building an uttaman to the
side uniform transfer to minors act for
some of it but be careful how your
programming everybody here because this
is a dangerous trend folks that people
are just completely abandoning education
because stupid people have been doing
education wrong I you know I understand
college is not for everybody I agree
with that but you know what we'll save
money for it
[Music]